when you travel to all these different
parts of the world which you realize
everyone is a human everyone is just a
person have you been to Japan yeah
they're odd they're the most odd every
since and I don't like how we can't
acknowledge it if they was normal we
wouldn't I think Japan is [__]
awesome I didn't say it's that
awesome I think Japanese people are
moving off of a ill honor Cod there's no
one at the grocery store it's just an
honor Cod leave the money the B A thatd
or good nobody's eating no no I'm saying
no employees to like make sure you're
not stealing you're Ste that's odd my
boy pass out Street shout out to Ben
woke up in the morning they had his
socks and shoes next to him and his
socks rolled up and stuffed into the
thing isn't that [__] incredible
that's odd cuz they was jerking off his
feet is thaten that's not that's not spe
where's the footage can I see it